non nous ne sommes pas dans le port de
marseille mais bien au milieu d'une
résidence dans cette cour d'immeuble
soixante dix containers en métal sont
empilés les uns sur les autres
habituellement réservé aux marchandises
ils servent ici de logements pour une
soixantaine de locataires
parmi eux hassan handicapées vivent
depuis deux ans dans un box d'à peine 11
mètres carrés c'est un déballage
normalement c'est un dépannage pour
lequel que quelques mois et puis ça fait
deux ans que je suis là voilà la veille
le fauteuil médical je ne peux pas n'est
pas de les utiliser à la regarde cette
année des crashes marché des télés ou
sexy je peux pas l'utiliser parce que le
trop petit et chaque fois je demande
c'est un peu plus grand marié fois temps
des vacances voilà j'attends ça fait
deux fois que j'attends comme hassan les
autres locataires de ces containers
habiter dans une résidence en rénovation
dans la tente de réintégrer leurs
appartements prévus en mars de l'année
prochaine
il paie un loyer de 400 euros pour ces
logements parfois sans fenêtre et à la
salubrité douteuses des races et a pas
saquer manque surtout à partir de 19h de
20 heures
on peut pas sortir ce sera on dirait
ceci des loups comme ça c'est trop ça
face à la situation
adoma le bailleur social a décidé de
proposer à la moitié d'entre eux d'être
relogés dans d'autres résidences du côté
de la mairie de la ville
l'impuissance domine le problème qu'a
rencontré adoma d'après ses dires c'est
que le chantier a duré beaucoup plus
longtemps que prévu suite aux
problématiques covit notamment l'année
passée mais que de quelques mois on est
arrivé à des hébergements sur du raid
plus de vingt mois voire certains disent
entre 18 et 24 mois
lorsque nous avons eu connaissance de la
situation nous avons effectivement et
j'ai personnellement appelé tout de
suite
le bailleur social et lui a demandé
immédiatement de d'intervenir en matière
de dératisation
si effectivement si le bailleur social
n'intervenait pas nous pourrions au
titre de la salubrité faire intervenir
des équipes pour constater l'état à
l'état des célébrités pour lui demander
d'une autre manière de prendre des
mesures éventuellement de demander à
l'état puisque là c'est l'état dont il
s'agit de prendre des mesures à sa place
dans le cas des règlements de salubrité
effectivement nous n'avons pas les
moyens aujourd'hui de garantir la
totalité que des personnes qui sont dans
des situations difficiles que la ville
va pouvoir trouver une solution pour eux
parce que la ville dans la pas la
capacité
dans un courrier adressé au premier
ministre
benoît payan maire de marseille a
demandé il ya quelques jours
l'organisation d'états généraux face au
logement indigne au squat et aux
bidonvilles au total plus de 40 mille
demandes de logements sociaux sont en
attente dans la cité phocéenne